what went wrong it is the putin system
that went wrong in this putin system
everything uh is
based on actually one
factor which is
survival of putting us as president of
russia
in most of cases
system putin has doomed
this part of the operation to failure
why because putin has
assigned his favorites into specific
positions within the russian armed
forces
so nobody is going to challenge him if
he's got a bad idea if he says you know
that i think this is what happens is it
very unlikely that the generals are
going to be like oh hold on a second
because if we do this and x is going to
happen
the problem is this is the way you see
it and this is the way plenty of other
people see it but putin in his own
position
he's constantly seeing himself
surrounded by competition by contra
hence by opposition or whatever you know
some kind of threat for him
it's different from his point of view
and this is what we have to keep in mind
that putin sees these things entirely
differently than you do than anybody
else does putin is putin he's not you
he's not me he's not somebody else he's
just put him for the best it's better or
in the interest of politicians and the
economy it's better to fight a war to
profit not to win because if you fight
to win you you know you send 1000
artillery pieces to ukraine ukraine
defeats russia tomorrow in the morning
and
the voice over
party's over yeah and what then
nobody's earning me anything from that
nobody
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissin
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is a
military analyst and historian who's
been one of the most objective voices
covering the conflict in ukraine tom
cooper welcome to trigonometry
thank you very much very nice to be with
you oh well it's great to have you on
the show so let's talk about the
conflict we wanted to start by
uh just recapping from the beginning for
people who maybe saw the initial events
didn't really follow everything that
happened so can you just talk us through
what happened in the initial phase of
the russian invasion
yeah sure what happened early on was
that uh
there was an attempt
uh obviously not even properly planned
but but driven by putin's demands for
russian or selected parts of the russian
armed forces to overrun the ukrainian
leadership
to to knock out specific
parts of of of or paralyzed actually
actually
uh parts of ukrainian armed forces
but foremost to to to
to overrun and and to
[Music]
decapitate ukrainian
political leadership which means
performance government
and the idea was obviously to to land on
four uh major airports around kiev
and from there to to to
drive into downtown kiev to
better kill or at least arrest the
government
and replace it but some by somebody who
would have been friendlier to putin
it was the original idea and because of
this
the initial uh ballistic and cruise
missile strikes are not as
intensive or as
uh
as or as effective as they
might have been if there was a wish to
really knock out the ukrainian armed
forces right from the start and to to to
destroy them so to say their leadership
as well
the idea was obviously to to capture the
government and that
everything was depending on the
dissolution capturing the government of
on removing it
and obviously there was a lot of
illusion about uh ukrainians so to say
rising to to
to to greet the russians coming in and
eventually three days later to help to
hold military parades in in kiev and
kaki when everything is fine and uh
great and ukraine is now russia again
it's it's really interesting the the way
you put that because it's inverted it's
in very simple terms now i'm going to
ask you a layman question tom and
take this
as broadly or as as as you want to
but what went wrong
because
when the when the invasion started i
think there were a lot of people
thinking well this is you know this is a
mighty power of russia against ukraine
they've got this huge army they've got
the weaponry they've got the men
why hasn't it gone to plan
what when what went wrong uh
it is the putin system that went wrong
in this putin system everything
is
based on actually one
factor which is
survival of putin as as president of
russia
retaining him in power so he can
continue
collecting cuts from
or cut from
all the possible enterprises from the
state and so on so in reaching himself
maintaining himself in power and his
fencing power
so in order for this system to survive
they have to lie all the time
and one of the lies is that ukrainians
would
be
some sort of
wealth more than brotherly people to
russia and because of this they would be
looking forward
to
to be
very unsc
russia
and that they would uh greet the russian
troops
and that they're they're
controlled by some sort of nazi
regime
uh which is suppressing them terrorizing
and genociding russians and so on so
this
basic idea
was a big lie
and it came so far that even putin lied
to himself
he he fell for his own illusions this is
what went wrong and because of his own
illusions he sent the
spetsnaz and and the vdb this is
airborne russian airborne troops
into ukraine under entirely wrong
conditions he has sent them in
expecting them to meet only light
resistance if at all
and you know to rapidly
achieve uh
their their that their aims
and this is what didn't work because
ukrainians those and even if there was
lots of chaos and even if there was you
know
shocked and surprised by this initial
attack
they they they took up arms and defended
and fought back
this is what what was unexpected for the
russians
and tom when you talk about things going
wrong uh when you describe the initial
phase of the attack which is attempting
to take over the airport and decapitate
the regime it sounds a little bit to me
like what a superpower might do to a
small country in the middle east you
come in you remove the the head of the
regime and then you take over and
obviously it didn't go down that way but
after that we obviously saw uh these
columns coming in from the north uh and
the big attack in the south and
obviously the push in the east and those
haven't even in the initial phase they
were they made some progress but they
were repelled can you talk to us about
that phase of the invasion as well
yes of course uh
yes it was an idea you know of a quick
quick takeover that was fundamental to
the entire
plan if if there was really a plan the
way the things looked like putin didn't
even discuss this plan with shoigu and
gerasimov he simply ordered specific
field commanders commanders of of
combined arms armies of the russian
ground forces
to
[Music]
let's say
for example move to brigade a from place
b to place c
and uh capture the government
it was that simple
and
then the idea was to follow up you know
because this light airborne troops and
special troops they cannot hold
any kind of area for for an extended
period of time they cannot do that on
their own because they're likely armed
and they cannot do that without supplies
this meant that
they have to
follow the light troops and this is also
part of standard russian
warfighting doctrine so to say
uh to
that to be followed by by
ground troops
which in the case of russia is always
mechanized units they do not call them
mechanized they call them tank units or
they call them motorized infantry or
whatever else but they are mechanized
units and they have to follow and to
secure to help the the the special
forces and and airborne forces to secure
the the areas they have
taken during the first
initial strike
and then came again what what happened
was next
was twofold
so to say in most of cases
system putin has doomed the this part of
the operation to failure
why because putin has
assigned his favorites into specific
position positions within the russian
armed forces
favorites who were
permitted to enrich themselves
on condition
of unaccountability to anybody except to
putin
and on condition
of
providing him with his cut from from all
the money that they were pocketing all
the time this is how putin system system
putin works
works so that you appoint your friends
and and
less of
family members but foremost friends or
aides or associates or whoever
into specific positions
where they are cashing
from uh
huge contracts there's
a signing with the state and then
they're overpricing all the time and
from this this income they are financing
putin and when he needs something
he just needs to call and he's getting
his money or his favors or whatever else
in
in return for this
for appointing people to such positions
and it's the same in the in the army
on the other side because of this the
army has never completed its reforms
it's it has never really
converted itself into a professional
force
and the the the generals commanding it
are incompetent they are putin's
favorites but they are not there because
they because of merits of because of
their skills or capabilities but but
because they are putin's favorites
sorry for this reason
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be my old wallet was massive so it
brought all the ladies to the yard which
was a huge distraction and got in the
way of my esteemed work on trigonometry
bridge wallets have an incredible
solution for you this is mine sleek
stylish and with an industrial look to
it you can fit 12 cards with cash on the
back using a clip like this one or a
strap we've got one for the whole team
i've got one francis has one even our
producer anthem has one but he's from
liverpool so he flogged his on the black
market the great thing about ridge is
that they give you a lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have
only one wallet for the rest of your
life ridge are so confident in the
quality of their product they will give
you 45 days to test drive their wallets
that means you can get the wallet use it
and if you don't like it you can return
it within 45 days
and that's not all for every dollar you
spent on the ridge wallets website
you'll be entered into a competition to
win a brand new upgraded ford bronco or
if you can't drive like france's then
you can win 75 000 in cash winners will
be announced in october so get spending
because ridge are such great guys
they're going to give you 10 off and
free worldwide shipping and returns to
take advantage of this incredible offer
go to ridge.com forward slash trigger
that's ridge.com forward slash trigger
and use our special code which is of
course trigger
tom isn't also part of the problem as
well like you've got a guy like putin at
the top who
to put it mildly is a little bit
ruthless right so
nobody is going to challenge him if he's
got a bad idea if he says you know that
i think this is what happens is it very
unlikely that the generals are going to
be like oh hold on a second because if
we do this and x is going to happen
the problem is this is the way you see
it and this is the way plenty of other
people see it but putin in his own
position
he's constantly seeing himself
surrounded by by
competition by contra hands by
opposition or whatever you know some
kind of threat for him
and this is why he has established for
example the ross guardia ross guardia is
a paramilitary force which is
responsible solely to putin it is not
responsible to to the minister of
defense in moscow
but it is as possible solely to put him
why because he wanted to make sure that
in the case that the armed forces would
stage a coup against him he hasn't it's
his own military force to counter such
an operation
so you have the lost guardian as a sort
of pretorian guard for putting
responsible solution to putin
you don't you do not you
barely see it fighting on the frontlines
in ukraine but it's always in the rear
securing the back the rear areas you
know the towns behind the front line
villages behind the front line checking
what is the local population doing but
also keeping an eye on the russian armed
forces fighting on the front line
so therefore you know
it's different from his point of view
and this is what we have to keep in mind
that putin sees these things entirely
differently than you do
uh
than anybody else does putin is putin
he's not you he's not me he's not
somebody else he's just putin
well tom as someone who's from russia i
hear everything you're saying and it's
very familiar to me both about putin and
the the military hierarchy and so on but
people would argue that uh while
obviously there were failures from the
russian invasion at the beginning they
did manage to capture significant
territory in the northeast around
harcouth
they managed to capture a huge swathe of
land in the south uh that's the point
yes
yes they managed to eventually grind
down their resistance in marijuana in
the southeast on the sea of azov and
capture that they've made significant
progress in the donbass
it's cost them a lot but they have over
the last six months
yes eventually they had to withdraw from
kiev and so on but they've still made a
lot of progress you would i think a lot
of people would credibly argue
why were they able to do that
that's the point
there was a part of the only part of the
russian what is initial putin's plan for
for for takeover of ukraine that that
did work was in the south
they are also the most
combat experienced element of the
russian ground forces was deployed this
is the 58th combined arms army
and next to it there was a 49th combined
arms army these two armies stormed from
crimean from the occupied crimean
peninsula towards the stores north
another 58 had a very
important task which was to reach
zachariah and to to
reach
mario paul from the west from the west
and uh the 49th had at least an as an
important task which was to to
[Music]
take care zone
take me collide and then advance all the
way to the border
with moldova
there there is a part of moldova east of
the the nest river
controlled by russian separatists
so-called sansnistria
and in that way
putin was aiming not only to to take
away the entire ukrainian coast away
from ukraine to bring it under his
control but also to establish land con
connection to the transnistria
and these two armies have thanks to
treachery obvious treachery on the part
of uh
i don't know exactly which
treason
yes
uh exactly treason by on the part of
higher ranking officers in the ukrainian
armed forces it has worked flawlessly
really they have reached castle within
two or three days no problem they have
they have uh closed the siege of mario
within two days the only thing that
didn't work
uh was
the capture of zaparoja
but otherwise it that this is what
brought the biggest conquest in
comparison
uh to this advance in the south you have
advanced in in in kiev area and chinese
areas in the north and in kharkiv all of
them failed
the 35th uh
combined arms army did manage to reach
outskirts of kiev but
in turn was almost cut off from its uh
supply lines and there was this huge
because there was only one highway it
could use to reach kiers
so it it was slow down bogged down by
its own supply problems the
41st combined arms army which was
advancing on chinese fell apart in the
process of advancing on cheney
in the face of relativity resistance by
by one and a half something like one and
a half ukrainian brigades so it fell
apart by advancing for 70 to 80
kilometers to change it
uh you have the first gods tanks army
the the elite of of
of the
of the russian armed forces it fell
apart by passing by sumi and trying to
advance towards uh kiev from the east
and uh worst of all
the two armies that were advancing that
that the task with capturing
kharkiv they also actually fall up fell
apart in the process
i mean there were only two ukrainian
brigades offering serious resistance in
the karaki area during the first week of
war and they didn't manage to to to to
drive
around the city they didn't even manage
to drive they did manage to drive into
the city for a few hours and they would
destroy it to the last almost
so this part northern part of the
invasion failed miserably
this is where the
russian armed forces fade on putin from
putin's point of view and this is why
he's
terribly mad about them already since
months
also why he's punishing them by these
constant orders for assaulting heavily
fortified
urban areas of eastern ukraine ever
since
on the contrary in the south he just you
know ordered okay you have taken what
you have secure it and that's fine with
me
they are not punished so much they are
even reinforced by the by airborne
troops now in august
so tom
looking at the situation now
do you think the russians are going to
be happy with what they have would that
would they regard
this invasion as a failure at this
particular moment
okay
when we talk about russians
i'm again i am a little bit insistent in
these regards there is putin
yeah then there are russian
nationalists chauvinists extremists
whatever we want to call them and then
there are russians okay
now putin is not happy
but because he's all the time forced to
downsize his aims for what he wants to
do in ukraine initially he want to take
over all of the country then just the
country east of the
nipro river then
then now you know just secure luhansk
and donetsk and and careson and
zapologia
meanwhile he is even to to less than
this and so on and so on then you have
the russian extremists
who whom who are actually misused by
putin for his purposes this is where you
get the story about our history of
russia and ukraine is so complex and
blah blah blah blah blah
that day dreaming about things you know
and have no actually no other purpose
but keeping or helping uh
keeps putting in power
most of them have actually no say in in
any kind of decision making they're just
you know led to to cash their income
from tv appearances and so on
or by
uh being representatives in the domain
in the russian parliament then you have
the rest of the russians and
what is this rest of the russians
actually doing this is majority of the
population over 90
nobody really knows because putin
wouldn't let us know
wouldn't even let him then know what do
they want
so some of them are probably pro putin
or at least for russia against ukraine
and
really convinced that ukraine is
controlled by some kind of nazi regime
others apparently do not care they want
to survive they they are fighting their
everyday life for survival
fighting their every everyday struggle
for survival nothing else you know
so it is i'm making quite distinctions
between this but crucial point is putin
is not happy with what he has achieved
or failed to achieve so far
and he is definitely determined to to
continue you know holding as much of
ukraine as possible
and tom this brings us nicely onto
last week's events where there was a
huge counter attack there was a small
counter attack in the south near hassan
and a big counter attack which was very
successful in the north
and
i am someone who's observing this
conflict and i i have my loyalties but i
also tried to be objective about it as
well of course and
while i was very happy to see the
counter-attack succeed in the way that
it did i was a bit concerned that people
in the west got over excited about it
because yes the russians abandoned a lot
of military equipment yes ammunition yes
land but they didn't lose huge numbers
of troops there was no major
encirclements how significant first of
all was the counter-attack what should
people in the west who are lay people
like us watching this take away from it
is this some
a lot of people seem to think this is
like the end of the war can you tell us
what this actually means
it is just another episode in this war
nothing else
uh
i have to
even if trying to explain this to a
layman i have to to go into a little bit
of technical details
for example the number of brigades
deployed in cassonne for this contra
offensive you know in late august is the
same like the number of brigades
deployed for this uh counteroffensive in
eastern kharkiv
a few days later so
the force
is not that
different or anything
where there is a difference is that in
in eastern khaki
the ukrainians have managed to find a
sector frontline
where the russian artillery was not that
over overwhelming them as it is on other
important parts of the frontline
and
this enabled them to concentrate
virtually
lots of forces which is some seven or
eight brigades on a very small area
to overpower quickly overpower the
russian frontline and punch through
to get into the rear of the russian
front line in cassonne they didn't
manage that feat yet
in cassandra all the time trying to
bridge the russian frontline but so far
have
with few temporary except exceptions
they have not managed to to
to reach this
breakthrough at operational level as
it's called in in military
uh vocabulary so
what happened then in casson they are
they have moved
lots of foreign but overall the russian
armed forces in casson are still
well depleted but intact they are still
operational
what happened in eastern kharkiv is that
once they have breached the front line
which was a sector of frontline which
was poorly uh
occupied by the russians
they have managed to drive through very
deep into the russian bank
what then happened was inertia so
so-called inertia
in response to several russian
counterattacks all of which came from
the north
the ukrainian troops moved or you could
involve ukrainian brigades moved towards
north too
it is also saw that
by trying to move from from uh balaclaea
towards the south towards the eastern
they were slowed down
by ever stronger units of uh russian
army
so instead on on issue
they went for coupons instead
this has collapsed the entire northern
section of the russian front line
really threw everybody into chaos and
this is what resulted in this massive
retreat and and lots of vehicles being
abandoned and so on
and ukrainians liberating you know
dozens
30 40 50 60 villages cupiansk and
everything else reaching the oscar river
but the actual aim of that operation
that is a guess i do not have any kind
of evidence for this but this is logical
was actually to to drive into the rear
into the back of the first guards tank
army in the easom area
and this is what they have
they have not initially managed
as first there was too much resistance
and second the road network
between kupiansk and issum there's only
one highway it is not a direct highway
it is not running around the roskill
river
so they had a problem to approach this
area and then they finally approached
ezio
they have uh
passed by the town because there were
too many russian forces in inside the
town and they were still resisting too
fiercely
and at that point in time it would have
been crucial for the ukrainian troops on
the southern southern side of the
resulting
bulge so to say to punch through the uh
to punch to the russian front lines and
to close the
uh the trap so to say around the first
gods army they have attempted to do so
but they didn't manage that
and this is why the the first guards
army actually managed to to to run away
to escape of course it has lost
what 100 150 tanks and
100 armored fighting vehicles
and so on but if you check the losses
you can see that
russia's lost very few are theory
during this operation it is something
like 1820 artillery pieces this is
nothing
one should keep in mind that the entire
russian frontline is held together the
fact by their a theory but a superior
artillery
so if they would have suffered a loss of
100
heavy guns that would have been a
massive loss for the russians but tanks
and
infantry fighting vehicles and armored
personnel carriers they do not putin
cannot care less because it's not
hurting him he has ten thousand of these
stored somewhere you know around russia
he can always replace them but artillery
pieces this would have been much harder
to replace
and on the contrary they have managed to
extract most of their artillery uh
towards swat to the stratovey area
and uh those
as much as
an immense success because especially
because you know it is uh
the first major ukrainian offense that
is that has really
been successful on its own so to say the
ukrainians have really beaten the
russians
and this is why events is important this
operation is far from ending this war it
is just another episode in this war the
first gods army has started itself the
russians have established a new front
line along the oscar river that's it you
know now the ukrainians have to find
another place
where they are going to to attack again
and perhaps achieve something similar in
the meantime we shouldn't forget that
russians remain on offensive on
initiative
all the way further down south you know
southeastern ukraine from they are still
attacking bachmat they are still
attacking along the former line of
control and so on and so on so it is far
away far away from from
from ending this war
and tom are there causes for optimism
because i i was reading some of your
articles on medium there's a lot of i
think it's um weaponry that the
ukrainians haven't have haven't yet
received yet
which means that they'll be strengthened
when it comes to the battles in the
coming months
for cautious optimism the point is that
yes the usa has promised yet more
weaponry but most of that is ammunition
ukraine is not about to receive yet more
heavier theory and that is the problem
russia remains superior
in regards of artillery and vastly
superior to ukraine
just like before these two operations
this is what is holding quests on
together russian forces in question
together this is why their frontline is
not collapsing because they still have
more artillery than ukrainians over
there which means
they they're still capable
of hampering ukrainian attempts to drive
between their
russian uh fortifications between
russian stoneholds and outflank them and
cut them off from their supply lines
this is this is the reason why that's so
important the artillery
and we don't
really don't
the west hasn't still hasn't taken care
to provide enough artillery to ukraine
this is not going to change anytime soon
why not tom why not
well
as we can see
it's a little bit complex issue
for example united states and the
european part of the nato have lots of
old artillery pieces caliber 155
millimeter in their reserve they are
stored
for 20 years sometimes longer and so on
they're not in use but they're not
delivering them what they do deliver are
artillery pieces or weapon system which
are currently in production
why because this is bringing profit
it means that the
governments whether the u.s or
governments of the
european part of the nato can spend to
buy yet more weapons that are currently
in production from
from the defense sector this is pure
profit profit nothing else this is the
only solar reason
is
sector the companies which are selling
these weapons which are manufacturing
them
sorry this is like in every in every
other aspect of our economic life they
are bribing governments to buy weapons
not to deliver
reserve or old ones from the reserve
that's how it works what i was going to
ask you then i suppose the obvious
question is
does the west actually want ukraine to
win
yes but
[Laughter]
the west does want to ukraine to win
but it's uh in the west you do not have
the politicians in the west they do not
have this clear idea of fighting war to
win
for them fighting a war is an
opportunity to profit for for companies
for private and corporate uh interests
supporting them paying their elections
election campaigns and so on
to to to
for such interest to to profit
so you have the same situation like all
the time since vietnam already vietnam
afghanistan iraq you know
for the west it's better or in the
interest of politicians and the economy
it's better to fight a war to profit not
to win because if you fight to win you
you know you send 1 000 artillery pieces
to ukraine ukraine defeats russia
tomorrow in the morning that is now
hyperbola and uh the war is over
party's over yeah and what then
nobody's earning anything from that
nobody but if you you know keep ukraine
afloat and supply it with weapons which
are currently under production
your sponsors in the rear the
guys in the shade in the shadow
they are profiting everything is fine
you know and we go on just like nothing
happened the only thing disturbing all
of this the party is is this
story with with uh
gas deliveries and and high energy
prices oh gosh this is a little bit
disturbing because you know the
population is against this and we have
to do something in the curb the high
energy prices so we have to keep this
under under control in order at least to
pretend
we are trying to keep them under control
and so on although it would be very easy
but well and let's live our democracy
in the economy
and tom what difference is winter going
to make to this conflict because it's
around the corner in a couple of months
and ukrainian winters
are notoriously bitter
yeah
well what is making it's going to bring
bigger advantages for ukraine
primary reason so far why the russian
armed forces were relatively successful
which is actually just one segment of
russian armed forces this is the ground
forces
have been successful the last let's say
since april since it
since it got warmer in ukraine
is the combination between their their
uavs orland 10
in particular and their artillery
holland 10 is a
very
rather or rather primitive
military system it's not even military
it's actually only the the few region
wings are military grade everything else
is actually bought on open market you
know canon cameras and canon video cam
video cameras and
and ecm systems everything they install
into these uavs
is civilian grade equipment which means
that it cannot work at temperatures
below five degrees centigrade
which in turn means as soon as it's
freezing outside the russians are going
to be blind
along the battlefield
and then they they're going to have huge
problems with finding the ukrainians
along with that this is why russians
have now rushed to buy uavs from from
iran because iran thanks to chinese
support and technical support and
know-how
and even organizational production in
iran
uh iran is capable of delivering
military-grade uavs
so the russians are obviously planning
to replace their
their own uavs which are useless in
winter by iranian uavs we're going to
see if this is going to be effective or
not but general ukraine should be on
advantage
so that's very interesting because i
would have thought that it would you
know it would help the russians because
they push them back and they can and
look again i'm a layman but you know you
can restrict you know the flow of goods
and whatever else he just thinks the
russians are invulnerable to the cold
yeah yeah
a long time around me yeah but i i would
have thought that they'd it would it
would help them to kind of not starve
the ukrainians out but certainly make
things far more uncomfortable for them
i mean we have to distinguish between
ukrainian armed forces and ukrainian
civilians
we have there are millions and millions
of ukrainians in eastern ukraine
feeling this war and their you know
direct impact upon their
everyday life
they are going to be freezing
they are going to be hungry and so on
and they are not going to survive
without extensive aid from from the west
and from here and so on
this is one part of the story but
ukrainian armed forces they have no
problem they are already in the process
of distributing winter clothing
and with winter equipment on their
to their troops so this is not going to
be that much of a problem floating food
fuel as you can see the ukrainian uh
supply system is working perfectly and
the russians have massive problems just
trying to find it
you know in order to hit it for example
from the air with with whose missiles
baristic missiles and so on they're not
successful in these regards
so this is not a problem
for the ukrainian armed forces on the
contrary because of the system putin and
because of all the lies at which they
are feeding their people for for decades
already and because
now they're starting to realize
the extension of these lies
the morale is very low
and then you have system putin in
regards of command system where the the
putin is bypassing all the normal
chain of command in the armed forces and
all the issuing direct orders upon field
commanders
which is spraying everything he's
throwing you know every single day he's
throwing the the russian military
doctrine and strategy out of the window
ignoring them completely and issuing
ever new orders for assaults on specific
objects and so on which result in heavy
casualties
but he can't care about this why because
he
thinks that his favorites
owe him a favor
or returning a favor all the favors he
has
granted to them
and so this is a vicious circle in
inside russia which is going to result
you know in in further debacles like
this one in eastern karaki now this is
going to happen time and again
however in between of this or such
tobaccos they are going to be you know
periods of many months
where the ukrainians will have to
maneuver to find such weak spots in
russian frontlines
to in order to exploit them that is
going to be crucial for the coming
winter
hey
do you want better mental health i'm
from russia we don't have mental health
so how do you deal with mental health
you drink vodka then go out and wrestle
bear if you live you feel better if you
die you're not real men what about the
bear's feelings it's russian bear it has
no feelings people don't always realize
that physical symptoms like headaches
teeth grinding and even digestive issues
can be indicators of stress and let's
not forget about doom scrolling not
sleeping enough sleeping too much under
eating and overeating sleeping too much
under eating this is western disease
therapy has really helped me in my life
to concentrate and focus it's really
important to have someone impartial who
you can talk to about the tricky issues
that you're struggling to deal with
therapy has played a really important
role in helping me to deal with my adhd
and become better in all areas of my
life
why is he telling them how weak he is
drink vodka feel better
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to trigonometry funds get
10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com forward slash trigger
especially if they're not real men
that's
t t e r h e l p dot com slash trigger
tom just a very quick question before i
move on the conversation uh what is your
estimate for casualties on both sides
uh i prefer not to mix into into such
discussions because we do not have any
kind of firm figures you know we have we
do have official
claims de facto from from ukraine we
have an external team from russian side
but we have nothing
really dependable in this regards
i do estimate that ukrainian casualties
are actually higher than russian
i don't know how much but it is it plays
in the nature of things they were they
were lightly armed uh and they are fully
protected especially early during the
war
and as much as more combat experience
than the russians meanwhile they are on
offensive when you're in offensive
you're automatically suffering heavier
casualties and so on and so on but
generally
i'm sorry for people who have
died
i'm sorry for those who even more for
those who who were maimed
or injured in whatever other
way
but
i find it pointless to talk about
casualties because it's it's leading
nowhere we're discussing propaganda from
both sides and discussing propaganda is
pointless
sorry for that no no of course i agree
that makes sense that's why i asked you
because i have no idea even though i
keep a pretty close eye on the conflict
because you
like you say both sides you know they
have
uh the point of communication and war is
to win it's not to communicate the truth
so uh you talked about you talked about
um
the civilian infrastructure and so on
and one of the things we saw as it seems
to me at least correct me if i'm wrong
is the immediate reaction from russia to
the harcav counter assault
has been to attack civilian
infrastructure power lines water supply
lines etc what do you make of that is
that just you know the russian regime
being angry and lashing out is it a more
strategic
what's going on there it's part of that
you know primarily it's a punishment
you shouldn't forget that as xkgb putin
is a foremost an extortionist
he's going to blackmail everybody and
everything he is ruling by blackmail he
came to power by blackmail he's ruling
by blackmail and his sole political
program is you know
whom can i blackmail today
and uh it is the same in this case okay
you ukrainians are resisting me then
have something of this here is your
resistance i'm destroying your your
infrastructure
it's as simple as that punishment as i
see and one of the things we talked
about earlier in the conversation that i
really wanted to discuss with you is you
mentioned that in addition to putin's
regime and ordinary russians there are
also another
sliver of people in between who are
actually protesting against putin
privately or in their private telegram
channels and whatever
who are saying that putin is weak and
he's not doing enough and what he needs
to do
is announce full mobilization
put the economy on a war footing
mobilize every man between 18 and 45 or
whatever it would be 35
and
announce that this is no longer a
special military operation
this is a full war russia is at war and
use the entirety of the russian
economy and military to defeat ukraine
that's what they're calling for
that hasn't happened so far do you think
it will no
it's not going to happen there are
plenty of reasons there are plenty of
reasons for this the first is it would
cost putin
putin lots of his money
which means what he is extracting from
the russian economy and state every
single day
that would cost it would cost him too
much for this second tom how much money
can a man need he's already one of the
richest people in the world i don't know
ask putin sorry i don't know
i mean he there are stories about him
bunkering what 800 billion somewhere in
the west or in china and wherever i
don't know how much more he needs
i don't know but he obviously
has no end of needs in these regards
okay but let's let's get back to your
earlier question uh the next problem is
that the russian state and
administration is
as we call it in german kaput it's
broken down i mean it's it's
bordering on collapse it's not working
so let's say you try to move he
announces general mobilization
first of all he would have a massive
problem just with you know how many
people would actually follow that call
there are
very informed russians who say more than
50 would would ignore it
it would be an absolute catastrophe for
for putting
then secondly
this would result in in huge gatherings
of armed people around russia
which is which is a threat for putin
sorry
whether they are controlled or not by
officers of his armed forces is
secondary it is a threat for putin
thirdly
what would russian armed forces get from
that they would get let's say one
million
perhaps two million of recruits
okay and who would train this all these
people who would keep them supplied who
would keep them you know warm
who tell them that to sleep by night
there are too few
officers and and non-commissioned
commissioned officers left in the
russian armed forces to do this kind of
job organization and logistics
for such a huge army so it would take
you know they will get millions of
people into the army and these would you
know stand around the barracks and
we don't know what to do because there
are too few commanders to command them
actually
just to command them not to talk about
training them
and then you have you know all of this
is rolling further who's going to issue
them with weapons who is going to train
them on weapons who is going to form
coherent units from them you know from
from platoon up to
company level to battalion level to
brigade level to divisional level
there is not enough of of officers there
is not enough of non-commissioned
officers left in the russian armed
forces to do the job
so what they are doing is to recruit
from
different associations veteran
associations
this is these are people who are already
who are already trained and they have
the history of service in armed forces
and they are already you know it's
easier to refresh their training in two
or three weeks and send them to the
frontline this is what they are doing
most of such people are ending
serving in in private military companies
which is one of the things which that is
that is
i would say quite ignored in the west
just how many battalion tactical groups
for example reduced
private military company or wagner which
is much better known
have on the frontlines meanwhile how
dependent
on their operations is put in meanwhile
this is something nobody's talking about
everybody's talking about russian armed
forces but whenever you check all the
major advances of russia over the last
four or five months it's always a
private military company that was that
led
the advanced you know the let the
penetration of the ukrainian front class
so but tom
working a different way it's worked
there is a mobilization already
to the pmc yes i want to come back to
the pmc but go ahead francis no but tom
see maybe i take a romanticized approach
to this and and i think to myself you
know nobody is going to fight harder for
their country than a ukrainian soldier
or a russian soldier what you're saying
is these people are effectively
mercenaries
but doesn't that mean that they're going
to have less allegiance to the courts
that they're fighting for because
they're they're there to get paid
essentially what should what should an
average russian fight for in ukraine
it's as simple as that
he i mean okay putin is promising you
know you can take loot with you and if
you get killed you your family is going
to get a new ladder oh great would you
like to go fighting somewhere for a new
ladder i wouldn't as simple as that so
you know what what putin is getting is
something
so to say outcasts in his armed forces
or or
weapons freaks you know such people they
are already serving in armed forces when
they got get shot away what he has to
find some kind of replacements so the
easiest way to finding a replacement
it's not a massive general mobilization
but recruiting veterans and this is what
he is doing and you this is how he come
already so far that even veterans of the
war of the soviet were in afghanistan in
1980s are serving on the frontlines i
mean these are people in their 60s yeah
so this is how it works in russia
because normal way doesn't work no what
is normal to you or to me
here in europe in the uk or in the
united states is not normal in russia in
russia has its own normality and this is
entirely different than in our case you
shouldn't forget that 50 of russians do
not even have a water closet inside
their home
they have to go outside into into some
kind of cabin
okay what should they what should they
fight for in in in in ukraine it's
either for loot or for
lada in the case they can't get killed
or something else but they they're not
for money or for money in a private
military company as you say so this is
what i was going to ask you about
because i agree with you i've been
following and it seems to me that all
the breakthroughs certainly in the
donbass are being made by these private
military companies so why is there
combat effectiveness higher because i
see videos of evgeny praguerian the head
of wagner recruiting people from prisons
now
how are they
that's what they're doing how are they
having such success relative to the rest
of the russian armed forces well
relative success because they are
drafting they are recruiting veterans
people who have combat experience who
have served
you for take for whether you take wagner
or or or redhoot these are the leading
private military companies in russia
especially but
let's ignore wagner which is well known
for a while let's take reduced reduce is
based
right next to
major airborne units
in in
peskov
area so this means their neighbor as
soon as you
the day after you have quit your service
in in the airborne forces you exit your
barracks and vis-a-vis there is a there
is a base of redhot
pmc
so what shall you do
russia is huge perhaps you have already
some other job perhaps you are going to
find
a job in some kind of private security
company inside russia or not
but let's say you know significant
percentage of cases you're not going to
kind to find any kind of
job or at least nothing better paid but
what red hood is offering
so you go to private military company
and
by serving such a company at earlier
times you had an outlook of you know
seeing something of the world serving in
syria
libya
in central african republic republic
excuse me i'm i'm smiling about this or
laughing about this because you know for
average russian it is a lot they do not
manage to travel around they do not have
the money for that it's true
yeah so what do you have
now if you have incentives okay let's go
serving in redhote and redwood is full
of former airborne troops
veteran airborne troops
and they are sent there that are sent to
kiev together with with uh airborne
troops and species at the start of the
war nobody's talking about this i don't
know why
but they were there they lost an enter
battalion tactical group
in kiev or on approaches to kiev
nobody's talking about that not even
ukrainians i don't know why
so it's it's a
strange situation actually we i think we
are not paying enough attention at this
aspect of uh
russian
war effort so to say but if you if you
check the associations of such of
veteran associations of paratroopers
urban troops of kozaks of this and that
this is over a million of people so this
is enough you know huge enough pool for
putin to recruit from them
and tom why isn't it if you say that
winter is going to favor ukraine more
why isn't putin just going to go
all in and just go right
we need to make the gains now
let's go all in let's demoralize them
let's defeat them
and let's get this over with as soon as
possible he's doing this all the time
he's doing this all the time the problem
is just that due to put system putin
it's not working
he was you know he was promising this
kingdom
hypersonic missile which is going to
destroy any kind of enemy which against
which there are no defenses how the nato
is crying about we don't have these
defenses against this weapon
and what happens
eventually kingship is uh impossible to
to make operational without
western
information technologies
so what happens then he fires one in
what was it april or something or march
he fires another one about a few weeks
later and then now he
has ordered a third deployment and the
missile just crashed inside russia
it's not working and why is it not
working again because of system putin
imagine running a high technology
enterprise under putin's rule you can't
do that because you need a huge
investment of money but putin is not
investing in into the russian economy
he's bunkering his money in somewhere in
the west or in china or wherever
so you are now a ceo of let's say a
small enterprise just launch something
in a garage
and you want to develop right
it's and uh
you want to to make hardware you need
hardware for such an enterprise whether
you get this hardware russia is not
manufacturing it you have to import
everything from the west
and this is already a crucial crucial
moment you you constantly need an intake
of
western high technology in order to
develop russian high technology
and you have a massive problem with this
this costs a lot of money which you
don't have because you all the time have
to pay put in his share as soon as you
are successful as an enterpreneur in
russia you have to put to pay put in his
cut otherwise you lose your enterprise
and he appoints one of his favorites
this is what's happening all the time
under portugal actually even for even
earlier
so it's not working the system is not
working it's collapsing all the time it
takes ages to collapse completely but
it's collapsing it's in the best way
and i suppose the question leading on
from that tom is how long other is putin
and the russian forces how long are they
going to have the stomach for this fight
because this can't carry on forever
surely
i don't know i'm not into predicting
future i don't have any kind of a
crystal ball to say but you know sooner
or later it's going there is going to be
a big collapse
right now the
the situation is still so that uh
that
russia is a fatalist or
yes how color else to describe them
enough to follow their orders the mass
of russian of uh troops are you know
they're like that okay you know i don't
have my own opinion
my superior commander told me this let's
go do that you know what's what he says
let's follow his orders that's the way
they think and when you when you
check some of the interviews of uh
russian prisoners of war taken by
ukrainian journalists there is one who
is specialized in such interviews
and you even hear from russian soldiers
they say i'm surprised how much are your
troops ukrainian troops free to decide
for themselves what are they going to do
you don't have this you don't
you don't even think that way in russia
you you receive your order and you
follow your order period that's it
that's what you do
in ukraine you discuss your order with
your superior officer you don't like
something you post a video on facebook
and say we have units so and so we are
refusing to fight because our
officer is corrupt or incompetent or
sending us into into into combat without
necessary support this is ukrainian
concept and it's work it works you know
actually you don't have you don't have
such a concept at all
and tom you were talking about the
military technology side of things which
brings us onto an issue we haven't
discussed yet which is of course
sanctions
and
i think the lay people in the west think
of sanctions as one thing so
military technology and oil and gas and
it all kind of just blends into one
thing and there's a lot of people saying
sanctions have been counterproductive
because russia's oil revenues are going
up
talk to us about sanctions are they
working which ones are good which ones
are bad you know what is the future of
all of that and what is the impact on
russia today
for the start matter of fact is that
putin's enter
military buildup it's a big show
actually but let's call it a military
buildup
uh was financed by the west so there's a
difference you know for the last 20
years and now from this
point of view it's
more important considering that the
mass of western customers for russian
oil and gas has signed long-term
contracts
you stipulate that either you buy it
or you don't buy it but you have to pay
so you have to pay no matter how much
have you have you have you imported from
russia
so in that in that regards you know even
if let's say let's say let's take
austria's example osteonor would would
say okay i'm i'm canceling my contract
signed last year by our holy chancellor
um who is now working for google by the
way
uh and and let's now stop importing
russian gas austria would still have to
pay several billions a year
even if not importing a single ounce of
russian gas and that until 2040 which
which is what 18 years from now
so
ideal situation for putin wait would
austria honor that contract in the
current situation
would austria sorry on another contract
would they pay
well austere would have to pay yes it
would have to honor it yes
what else you guys take your rules too
seriously
it is it is the way the world is made
there is no reason there is no superior
reason the god didn't show himself up
and and said oh you're austria i'm not
going to to import russian oil anymore
what else should happen a huge a massive
supernatural or natural catastrophe
destroying the whatever but russia but
austria has to to continue importing and
foremost it has to continue paying
germany is the same case
france it's italy in front of france the
same case this is why putin hasn't
cancelled these contracts yet he could
cancel them like he has cancelled in the
case of the netherlands
in this case he didn't con cancel the
contest because he's profiting anyway
from this
and uh okay of course our government
could now say well
okay we are going to cancel this
contract but then we have to pay
penalties
even more so because the contract
stipulates that we have to pay continue
paying whether we buy whether you import
or not so no it's okay so those
sanctions i am assuming are not going to
have the effect the west wants what
about military technology transfer
very much it is for example the the
freezing of uh federal russian reserves
had put in massive it took away
something 25 percent of his money
uh then
high technology freezing high technology
this is by far not exploited enough this
this this field
one could really penalize russia much
more in these regards they are still
managing to buy if nothing else from
japan and from china you know okay china
is even more reluctant to to sell high
technology to russia these days than
japan is or south korea is
so
there is still a lot opportunity in this
regard some could still hit russians
much harder in these regards but
it shouldn't mean that sanctions are not
hurting russia they are hurting it badly
and we are going to see how much just
during this winter and it starts hurting
the russian population as well
uh
what's that going to look like tom when
you say that it's hurting
what is that what are we going to see in
russia well in worst case uh what is
sometimes around 1917 that russia do not
like to be hungry and freezing in winter
it could happen the same it could could
you know could be the same exactly the
same
like in 1917
there it was women working in ammunition
factories which roses first and then the
october revolution began
we are going to see perhaps it's going
to happen perhaps not i don't know but
it could happen let's say this way
so
are you optimistic about the future tom
has this good better
generally i am generally i am because uh
generally i see humanity as a positive
positive
i said is uh positively developing uh
appearance in the nature
uh i mean we we are doing lots of
idiotic things and killing our each
other and killing the nature and so on
but sooner or later at least five before
12 you usually
get sane you know after hitting the wall
with with our foreheads some 500 to 1
000 times usually gets sane and
reasonable and and starts doing things
the right way so i think it's going to
be this way in this case as well i'm i'm
i said i'm generally i'm i'm i'm
optimistic about the future
well on that happy note at least uh tom
we will wrap it up there we're going to
ask you a couple of questions for our
supporters that they've already
submitted for our locals but before we
let you go and by the way thank you so
much for this i'm sure we would love to
have you back when there's more
developments in in in this conflict in
the future um but uh the question we
always ask our guests before we let them
go is what is the one thing that we're
not talking about as a society that you
think we really should be
except for this war
now i i mean this seriously i i think we
should generally be discussing uh
putin's uh
involvement in subverting the interwest
and democracies this is uh
that there are several books
at least one of which i could recommend
right away
uh this is discussing this but it's
still not enough but he has seriously
subverted our societies i mean from
inside out
and uh we are feeling this every single
day and it's not just in the uk not just
in france not just in austria or germany
it's really everywhere but
he's he has the presence behind the
curtain so to say and he's still pulling
strings around
this is one of the things and the other
thing what does that look like
what are you talking about
putin has a massive
they call this black cash massive
amounts of
money
on accounts owned by his favorites in
the west and he is
with help of this cash he's
influencing even the justice systems of
of entire countries uk in between of
this not only usa but uk and and france
and austria and so on so this these are
immense volumes of money which is using
to subvert our societies and this is
what i think
should be intensely discussed
and sorted out
you know
nothing happened so far to anybody in
these regards nobody was you know
made responsible for for for letting
himself or herself being bribed by all
this money
but it is actually this destructive for
our societies
i agree with you uh tom cooper thank you
so much where can people uh read your uh
updates uh tell everybody where to find
your work online
well it's the easiest it's on medium.com
if you check uh
ukrainian war and tom cooper you can
easily find a link
i mean if i check the link just a second
precisely medium.com
uh flash
at
it's been an absolute pleasure we're
going to uh
have some questions from our local
supporters just afterwards but thank you
so much for coming on the show you've
been a wonderful guest and very
illuminating
very much my pleasure thank you very
much for for inviting me to this show
and if you've enjoyed our episodes they
always go out on wednesdays and sundays
7 p.m uk time 2 p.m eastern standard our
raw shows go out thursday friday and
saturday and for those of you who like
your trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
uh barten-cessna says how significant
are china uh to russia and russia to
china
military relations and could they become
more significant uh given attrition in
the russian military at the moment
[Music]